hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge reis
auf dem col das erste video von diesem
schwierigen und alle meint nicht sollen
zweiten teil machen deswegen macht das
jetzt wir haben noch immer diese ukulele
droge dass wir irgendwie doppelt so
schnell sind und bleibt meine fresse
wir töten jetzt mal hierhin vitello eben
kurt und jetzt hatten wir den ich
letztes mal schon geholt ich teste jetzt
mal ob ich die videos darunter töten
kann indem ich einfach mal auf die drauf
was ich wollte ein spiel was ich einfach
mal ziemlich hochladen kann wo man wieso
habe ich eigentlich wieder leben
verloren ich aber beide getötet
stattdessen ist einfach ein spiel in dem
ich nur eins sagte hier sind checkpoint
es gibt einen fucking shop bei allem
respekt ich hätte somit spielen
gerechnet wo ich ganz locker durch
steige und einen part und alles ende und
hier gibt es den shop wo bin ich denn
hier gelandet die haben abwehr stufe
reize gesetzt mir aufgefallen dass diese
texte die ihr eingeblendet werden dass
ihr die irgendwie gar nicht angezeigt
bekommt oder habt ihr das gesehen ich
weiß es nicht und jetzt hörte ich die
vita los
wieso kann ich ihn töten was soll das
und sobald ich da raus springen will sie
ziemlich april
alt aber dass eine schwere geburt gerade
okay wo muss ich jetzt hin ich spüre
dass da unten wieder ein vitello mich
töten meine fresse nicht nur ein
mein gott ich kann mit diesem komischen
teilen kann ich die flaschen abschießen
die vitale auf mich schießt das heißt
wenn wieder nichts davon da kommt und
mich anschließend ihr schon kann ich
manchester spitze ich spring jetzt
einfach mal nach hier vorne auf [ __ ]
direkt zwischen zwei wieder los
mein handgelenk ich spring jetzt einfach
mal nach ich hab weggedrückt was da kam
ich kann hier nicht ich kann nicht hier
weg das ist ja klasse jetzt hier darauf
erstmal dann hier drauf hier drauf hier
vorne luca töten genau so und jetzt hier
drauf und und jetzt springe ich mal
hierüber hat super geklappt you can't
wait to hast eine neue fähigkeit
erhalten du kannst nun die zeit
kontrollieren drücke shift um die
fähigkeit sagte wissmann die situation
brauchen zum beispiel zum ausweichen von
schüssen
wir haben slow motion aktiviert gerade
scheiße was soll ich denn jetzt machen
mein plan ist jetzt
das packt mich einfach nur noch ab hier
vorne auf den tempel drauf hier auf den
kumpel hier darauf hier vorne luca töten
jetzt hier runter und luca töten und
jetzt hier drauf und jetzt
andere youtuber sind dafür bekannt dass
sie besonders viel schreien ich bin
einfach nur dafür bekannt dass ich die
ganze zeit irgendwie einfach nur die
face kämpfe und mir denke was für eine
scheiße guckt euch das mal an freunde
man kann nicht dazwischen stehen man
kriegt immer immer schaden und und
checkpoint wieso kriege ich den denn nie
ich habe wieder das low motion tool und
warum ich denn sagen kann ich die teile
töten mit meinen noten
ja ich hab die lösung und jetzt kann ich
nämlich theoretisch ein checkpoint habe
jetzt hier diesen check point erreicht
haben und hier hinten tatsächlich auch
wieder auf mein gott hier geht er wieder
richtig ab alter wenn ihr noch einen
nächsten part reise ukulele sehen wollt
dann zeigt mit einer bewertung und bei
400.000 daumen hoch mache ich noch ein
außerdem sind die puhdys wieder in allen
größen im shop vorhanden
die da vorne die was war nochmal die
top-adresse und dann würde ich sagen